Smith, Hassan said he want that that that smoke this week. >> Pull
up. >> Yeah, I do. I do want the smoke.
I know what you're going to say. You're going to say the
>> I'll tell you about Destiny. Yeah, it's
Not good when in the middle of your rant rant you got to go,
"I'M NOT BOUNCING ON ANYTHING. I'M NOT BOUNCING ON I STOP SAYING
I'M BOUNCING ON SOMETHING. WHAT THE GUYS,
SO, Hassan and Dave Smith were I guess Dave Smith had messaged
Hassan on Twitter and I didn't see what really happened. But
we can take a look, okay? Are people saying Hassan your rage
stuff? Okay, Hassan and your rage.
Just chatting. >> Get the nicest hotel room in New York
City. He can kind of afford it. He's pretty wealthy. Yeah, and
there are other cities in red states that would be happy to have
him and his
Dave Smith on his latest YouTube called you one of the dumbest
people, said he tried to debate you and you chickened
Oh, no way Hassan gets caught by this, right? There's no way
Hassan reads this and gets baited into leaking DMs based on a
chat message, right? Chatters are unreliable. You can never ever
ever just believe
chatters with like nothing to Dude, you need to validate that.
Say, "Send me the clip. Send me the clip." He said that? Send
me the clip. But I I've no doubt Dave said it, but I'm still
saying you you shouldn't get baited by They love him. The people
love him. He's one of the most popular podcasters in the country
right now. want more of this because what a lot of these entrepreneurs
are going to realize is that Okay. You think he'd ever run for
president? Dave Smith on his latest YouTube called you one of
the dumbest people, said he tried to debate you and you chickened
out. >> Your rage just trying to talk about politics, Hassan?
Dave Smith on his latest YouTube video called you one of the
dumbest
Hassan's triggered, okay?
Your rage Your rage is just sitting here trying to talk about
politics, man. Come
>> cuz I'm just going to leak the DM.
Drama Dame 714, I see it. I see the >> Okay. Drama. Yo,
what's good? Clippers. You know what I'm saying? Oh, wait. >> I just
straight up said, "We don't agree on much, but I will give you
Here, I'll just show it to you right now, actually.
Look at that.
Wait. Oh, it just shows this one. "We don't agree on much, but
I will give you Prosser holding firm on Israel from all the stuff
I've seen of you. April 10th, 2025." No response.
So, I don't know where the He said you ducking. I don't know
where the he's coming That doesn't really seem
That doesn't seem bad at all. This is Hasan going, "Hey Dave,
nice job, man." Right? Well, that That was Hasan, right? Yeah,
that's Hasan. That's why you get the check mark like that. "for
holding firm on Israel from all the stuff I've seen of you."
>> big of a I thought the leak was going to be worse than
that. Come on. >> So, I don't know where the He said you
ducking. I don't know where the he's coming from. >> Smith,
Hasan said he want that that that smoke this week. Pull up. >> Yeah,
I do. I do want the smoke. I don't know why he's like I didn't
even know that there was smoke, but [__] it. Who
else you want to smoke with? Who else you want to debate? I got
you. I said that. All right, you got it? >> I got you.
Who else you want to debate? >> Okay, I'm going to I'm
probably going to debate Sean Hannity, the guy who just you just
saw. We're setting that up right now. Okay. >> Leaked it.
Get Why not? >> Oh, [__] Is that news? Yeah,
that's news, yeah. Uh he about to debate Sean Hannity? Yeah,
Patrick Bet-David. I would love to go Yuriy doesn't know who
Sean Hannity is >> No, he's showtime. >> Doesn't
care about Sean Hannity. >> You know Patrick Bet-David?
Uh I know of his name.
>> really know his like views and [__]
They're all right-wing. Okay. Okay.
Uh what else? What else? What else?
Asmongold. Set it up. I need that. Asmongold ducks me like crazy.
He would never do that. SQC. Go ahead. Hasan shouldn't talk about
ducking cuz I know YURP should ask him if he's going to debate
Destiny, right? That has to happen here. I feel like YURP is
definitely going to bring that up. He's going to mention him.
Not By the way, not because YURP wants to see that debate, although
he might, but mostly because YoruRage knows that will quit with
Hasan and he can farm drama off of it, right? 100% I There's
no way. I would be so shocked if he doesn't. >> and what
actually I'm talking about like >> I see your emotion.
You have like 27k and on top No, it's not even like the the numbers.
>> political political relevance. >> Yeah, it's like
debating It's like playing chess with a pigeon. You know? What
the [__] am I I I see now why xQc was so mad.
I feel like I've seen so many xQc clips the past 2 days and now
it all makes sense. That that Hasan was talking [__]
to xQc and x is that Hasan's been talking [__] Cuz
I I swear I've seen xQc talking [__] in like five
different clips now in the past maybe 2 3 days. Not that he didn't
talk [__] before. He's just like upped it. What am
I going to do with that? At least with Asmongold he has like
uh people that watch him for his political takes. >> Well,
I heard him say he don't like talking to people cuz he like to
stay in his bubble or something whatever he >> Yeah, yeah,
that's cuz he's a
That's what it is.
You'll say that to his face though. You'll you'll You'll say
that to his
Oh, you're trying to instigate. Yes, I >> You'll you'll
say that to his face. Yes, I would. You'll call Asmongold [__]
to his face next time you see him at TwitchCon. I'm not going
to TwitchCon. Dude, if YoruRage like Listen, I don't I don't
think Hasan would talk to Destiny and I don't need Hasan. Like
I I don't even think that's a good or sensible like thing to
ask, right? For multiple reasons. But, if YoruRage doesn't bring
it up, he lost, okay? This is This is so easy to just quit with
Hasan. Just for the sake of his own content, all right? I don't
know. If I did, I would not have an issue doing that. >> So,
let's say you find out >> I was supposed to debate Charlie
Kirk and then he died.
Oh. You think Asmongold's going to be going to TwitchCon? Yeah,
Asmongold's not going. Oh, he don't go outside at all? Oh, [__]
Yeah, we got chat vice, yeah. Does he Does he look like Does
he look like he goes outside? All right, all right. Who the [__]
was that? What the [__] was Where did that come from?
Who is that?
I know somebody I want you to debate, but I ain't going to say
it though. That was Rogan. I know what you're going to say. You're
going to say the past I'm talking about Destiny. Yeah. He just
Sorry, I Listen, that's purely from a [__] disturber
perspective. I'm like, you got to bring it up. You got to say
it, right? I'm like, dude, you got to be a [__] disturber.
You got to do it. You have You can't not do it. It's free. It's
so free. I know somebody I want you to debate, but I ain't going
to say it
I know what you're going to say. You're going to say the
>> I'm talking about Destiny. Yeah.
past the name Bro, he good at debates. He is good at debates.
I've you know, I I recognize that. All right. Welcome to Chat
Vice Chatter. What's your name? >> You're Okay. >> Yo,
howdy. Sam, nice to Okay, they do Collins. Yoruichi, perfect
flawless segment. Yoruichi missed Listen, if Yoruichi was playing
any random game, all right, that was 100%. He just 100% that
route, okay? He's just like 100% he hit everything everything
you needed to to farm maximally for that He hit all of it, okay?
Perfect. 10 out of 10.
Fantastic work. The timing was great. He missed zero pickups.
Let's go. All right, we continue from here to the Substance clip.
So, Substance clip something from the next day, all right? Did
you see Dave So, Dave Smith says he challenged us on to a debate
a few times and then Hassan just ended up running. Hassan claims
that not to be true. Did you see Dave Smith did a 30-minute segment
on you on a show and all of his fans in the comments were on
your side? I did not. I don't know why people keep bringing this
up. Someone said Dave
claimed that I chickened out of talking to him. Hasan [__]
a lefty streamer who's very popular. He is very dumb. I've always
found him to be laughably unimpressive. If you remember, Rob,
we've done a few episodes over the years where he had segments
on us and we did responses to it and I challenged him to debate
a few times back in the day, which he was never interested in
doing. Dave Smith never replied to my DM.
I literally DM'd him giving him props. I was like, "We don't
agree on much, but I wanted to give you props for holding firm
on the Israel stuff." And he never responded to my DM. Did you
see Dave Smith
I don't know I don't know why
I'm trying to think, why wouldn't he
Why wouldn't Dave Smith be like, "Hey, would you want to debate
on something?" Why wouldn't you take that as a lead-in to go
like, "Hey, would you want to collab on something?"
It just feels like you'd want to use that to try to force some
sort of conversation, right?
No? Am I crazy? That's got to be That's got to be the case. Dave
doesn't want to? I don't see why not. Dave Dave would obviously
disagree like mightily with Hasan on a couple things. I don't
see why he wouldn't call in. Okay, from
we get actually, unironically
Dave Smith responding to this this
Dave Smith lying on Hasan?
It is true that I challenged Hasan to debate years ago. I did
it publicly on my podcast. This is verifiable. Okay.
I mean, there's
I challenge Dave Smith to a debate right now. On what topic?
I have no idea, to be honest with you. But it's like Is that
really challenging somebody to a debate like if it doesn't get
clipped, see it if you have no idea if they see it or not? Dave
Smith's challenge comes from literally this week, right? No,
he's saying way like a long time ago. It is also true that Hasan
much more recently sent me a message giving me props that I didn't
respond to. There is zero contradiction here. Now, stop stealing.
So, Dave Smith, you know, he quote-tweeted, he responded. Hasan
responded. What?
Hasan responded directly.
You know, you can respond to me via DM,
I don't know what this one-sided boxing thing you're doing is.
We can talk about whatever you want or we can talk about whatever
you want to talk about, man.
So, does Dave Smith respond directly or do we Yeah, maybe he's
talking to one of those like bots who is like Dave Smith Uh do
you want to see my
Dave Smith, I'm Hasan [__]
I I fully maintain that the funniest moments on Hasan's stream,
maybe the only funny moments, are when he's doing a voice, okay?
Yeah, I've got all the other followers so thank you.
and I will do debate with you.
I'm Hasan [__] do you want to see my
Please click on crypto wallet link. Ooh, I'm horny for debate,
Dave Smith.
Why does he do these voices?
Beyond the fact that it's funny, I Come on, I heard I heard somebody
say that lefties aren't allowed to do these voices. They're too
offensive. He's to stop doing the voices, man. What the hell?
What the hell, man?
Okay, Dave Smith quote tweets and
Here's the Dave Here's the first Dave Smith response, okay? Did
you think I was trying to message you and accidentally just did
the podcast did a podcast instead? What does this mean? You've
done several segments on me in the past. Was that one-sided shadow
boxing? Do you want to debate if advocating stealing is good?
I'm down. I mean, Hasan shouldn't debate this cuz you shouldn't
you shouldn't broadly say it's like good to steal. I Man, you
definitely shouldn't. I don't even think lefties should argue
this. I think it's a bad argument from the lefty perspective,
too. Just trying to say like it's okay to steal or it's good
to steal. It's like objectively just bad. All right, so what
is Hasan going to say in response? I can set up a debate whenever
you want. I'm saying you covered I'm saying you covered that
you wanted to debate me on your podcast. I don't recall. However,
I am asking why you haven't communicated this directly to me
and were claiming I am ducking you when I'm clearly not.
He'd be happy to host a the We can even bring in additional moderators.
Ooh, whatever. Trying to get on that. Whatever podcast.
He the quotes. I think Dave quotes this. Okay, let's go. What
did I claim you were ducking me? I responded to segments you
did on me did about me years ago and challenged you to a debate.
If you're unaware, then I take you at your word. I'm down. What
do you want to debate? I feel like Dave implied that
uh streamer who can doubt of talking to him. Hasan [__]
a lefty uh streamer who's very popular. He is very dumb. I've
always found him to be laughably unimpressive. If you remember,
Rob, we've done a few episodes over the years where he had segments
on us and we did responses to it and I I challenged him to debate
a few times back in the day, which he he was never interested
in doing. Uh Dave Smith never replied to my
I lit challenged him to a debate a couple times back in the day.
I feel like that's I feel like that's implying that
you message him, reached out in some way, went through a third
party.
I I do feel like that's implying he's ducking you. I challenged
him to a debate a couple times. Right? That's kind of implying
ducking. Maybe not like harshly. I'm not going to call him a
liar, but I feel like for the sake of of gamesmanship, he was
definitely saying like, "Yeah, he kind of ducked me, man. He
kind of ducked me, man."
I don't think that's crazy for Hasan to say. I don't think that's
crazy for anyone to say. All right, we got the Andrew Wilson
reply, too. You think You guys think Hasan is going to debate
Andrew Wilson? See uh same offer for me, Hasanabi
This is the pettiest This is just the most petty small thing
I've ever seen from not ever seen. It's like the most petty small
thing, cuz obviously it's not this instance alone. But when you're
like asking somebody for something, you misspell their name.
I presumably intentionally, since you're quote tweeting it, you
see it right
To me, I'm just like, dude, I find that performative rudeness
so annoying. Do you know what I mean? Like you're
Are you a [__]
I just feel like it's moronic. It's all It always comes off as
totally moronic to me. There's no way There's just no other way
to explain it or talk about it. It's just completely moronic.
The hell, man. I thought it was interesting. We're apparently
going to get a Dave Smith versus Hasan [__] debate,
which I'm excited about. Would love to see that.
Someone was watching Dave Smith slander on the stream like 40
minutes ago. Well, for the sake of the segment, maybe we got
to go check that out. Hold on. Let me see here. Is this going
to be good? It is true that I challenged Hasan to a debate. The
[__] I don't remember this at all. It is also true
that Hasan much more recently sent me a message giving me props
and I didn't respond. There's zero contradiction here. Now stop
I'm so confused. This is like doing drama with me and I don't
even have any beef with him. It's so strange. Dave Smith lying
on Hasan. Comic Dave Smith says he challenged Hasan the Hunt
to a debate a few times and Hasan just ended up running. Hasan
claims that not to be true setting a DM he sent Dave Smith giving
him props and Dave never responded to it. He's like it's it's
weird because like I guess he's shadowboxing me.
But also
it's not even a fight.
Like I want to have a tickle party and this shadowboxing me instead
and I didn't even know he was shadowboxing me. So why is he coming
out like this? Is it very strange.
Very strange behavior, bro. He's been talking to someone completely
random pretending to be you. Yeah, maybe he's talking to one
of those like bots who is like I'm Hasan [__]
Please click on crypto wallet
and I will do a debate with you.
I'm Hasan [__] Do you want to see my
Please click on crypto wallet link. Ooh, I'm horny for debate,
Dave Smith.
The clip with YourRAGE and XQC XQC responding to it. This is
one of the clips I talked about, all right? So, let's see basically,
YourRAGE was clip farming.
Hasan talking to him.
Let's see Let's see XQC's response. ducks me like crazy. He would
never do that. XQC, go ahead. XQC is irrelevant. I don't want
to debate and waste time with XQC. I'm talking about like
>> seconds to beat that [__] with my No, it's
not even like the the numbers. >> about political political
relevance. >> yeah. It's like debating one g. >> Now
Now, image imagine trying to trying to play this game where you
think it's because I have no political whatever. Buddy, buddy,
buddy. Hasan takes a W where he can get it. Trust me. But, he
wouldn't get a W. That's the thing, though. Is that genuine On
some of these topics that they would debate, bro, genuinely,
he would just lose. It's just that simple. Bro, something should
have it actually Dude, XQC After XQC didn't watch the whole clip
on Hasan earlier, I really think he just needs to be like careful.
He He has a He has such a big head on stuff. When it comes to
debating him in
Dude, we watched He watched that New York Times thing on Hasan.
He didn't see that Hasan was prompted. Hasan's not like defending
killing people at all. He's basically saying, "This is why people
feel this way." And XQC didn't look at the context. He didn't
look into it any further. He just kind of popped off and embarrassed
himself.
And then he's like, "Guys, I would cook this guy on on a bunch
of different topics." I bet you that New York Times clip is one
of them. I hope not. For his sake, I really hope not, okay? >> it.
Come on, bro. I'm not I'm not just some bum. Like Like playing
chess with a you know? Imagine what he would do to him. I'M NOT
JUST A BUM, BRO. I'm not just a bum. Chat, this is like if if
>> 66 months >> give a good example. This is the
exact scenario, chat, of Magnus
and uh and Hans Niemann, right? Where if Magnus wins, it's not
a big W, but if he loses, it's a massive L, right? And it's
I don't know how I don't know how to tell xQc this, but to compare
the Maybe maybe in that one way, okay? Maybe in that one way
that like if Hasan were to lose a debate badly to xQc, it'd look
bad for him and wouldn't look like xQc wouldn't look bad if he
loses. Maybe. Maybe. But to compare Hasan or xQc, Hasan to Magnus
Carlsen in debates, that's pretty crazy. And then also xQc to
Hans Niemann even, also crazy. Very very crazy. >> it because
of certain factors. And then he loses and it it causes complete
disarray. You know what I mean? Because his Elo would not gain
a lot because in the political world he's seen as like some form
of high Elo and I'm I'm saying it's low Elo. So even if I put
a dent in him, right, in a debate, then he loses a lot of a lot
of rating. Wait, why does he hate you? Bro, Well, why does So,
this is 7 years. >> you even begin at that point? Yeah,
7-year stalking uh situation with his entire community.
Um but uh I think it's mostly envy. That's what I would say.
He He thinks he deserves the the situation that I'm in and he
will never Oh my god.
I mean, I xQc's going to say some xQc's going to say some here
and it's not going to look good. Hold on. Let's see. Cuz I would
say envy might be what it is. I think it I think envy might actually
be the best description of why Destiny hates Hasan. >> deserves
the the situation that I'm in and he will never Oh my god.
It Is he talking about Destiny?
Chat, is he talking about Destiny?
I I know he's talking about Destiny. There's no way.
It Is he talking about Destiny?
Chat, is he talking about Destiny?
I I know he's talking about Destiny. There's no way.
No, Destiny.
That's [__] insane.
Brother, that Oh my god, I can I Is it? [__] Chat,
how many times have we gone through the I have we reacted to
clips where like I always tell you guys dude, he sees the world
in a certain way and he will not
ever entertain that people see the world a different way. Like
he sees clout and
as like the most like
like the the loot that everybody's locked up because he sees
it like right?
And he projects on everybody.
Any time he speaks about me, he
Is he projecting though or or was you know, is he projecting
though?
Remember this, January 2024, I will have more concurrent viewership
than Hasan by
When he's within he's when Sorry, when he's within that 6 months
of October 7th, he's feeling like a big guy. He's a He's He's
locked in.
He's locked the [__] in. All right, guys, he's locked
in. All right, it's crazy. Dang, what happened? Well, a lot of
things went wrong. I think also just generally this was
This was like at Hasan's lowest I think was around This is around
the time him and Ethan were basically on the rocks or splitting
up, right? And Leftovers was falling apart. That was like Hasan's
lowest point viewership I think for a
I just I Listen, I I do think it's envy and I do
I think Destiny cares about the viewership a lot. >> does
the same way about me. And like brother, but Destiny has never
given a [__] about this. Like Destiny peaked Okay,
okay, I'm not kidding. You might You might not
Destiny has never given a [__] about this. Destiny
has never given a [__] about this. Bro, what are
you talking
Who is this person you've made up that doesn't exist?
Destiny Destiny Destiny Destiny Destiny Destiny Destiny Destiny
Destiny doesn't even about this.
By the way, this is in the context of a conversation where Destiny
is watching his community watch Hasan.
Hold on, where is this here? I'll I'll have more concurrent viewership
than him. 16.5k
viewers with my audience watching plus reviewing this debate.
What the [__] So he's commenting on Hasan's fallout.
He's commenting on Hasan's views and saying he will have a bigger
viewership than Hasan. Like it's objectively the exact thing
that Hasan's talking about and XQC is just so out to lunch here.
He has no idea what he's talking about.
Sad. Very sad.
Very, very sad. We go back to the clip though cuz we're not done.
We got a minute 15 left on this clip
>> Destiny peaked before Twitch.
Destiny had 7,000 viewers on Justin.tv. Let's get goofy. >> cared
about views, he could have been on top of Twitch for for a decade.
Bro, he got banned and he didn't bother to say sorry or to try
to play the game. He just didn't give a [__] Went
live on YouTube and he's doing his own The guy doesn't give a
[__] Like
You know, I that's just wrong. He He moved on.
But like to say he doesn't give a [__] that's crazy.
Obviously he gave a [__] >> I'm not bouncing
on his I'm not doing SAY IT 1G.
NOT GOOD WHEN IN THE MIDDLE OF YOUR RANT RANT YOU GOT to go,
"I'M NOT BOUNCING ON ANYTHING. I'M NOT BOUNCING ON I STOP SAYING
I'M BOUNCING ON SOMETHING. WHAT THE GUYS. >> I'M SAYING
that he doesn't give a [__] about the cloud thing.
He doesn't care. Like you can say that Oh yeah, you can say it's
so expensive on him. He can say all this [__] Yeah,
maybe true this and But views Destiny bro, please just stop.
>> I mean he's a bad person. I was like yo Views Destiny
views Destiny views that It's just like the person he thinks
exists doesn't.
Sad. I I I don't know what else to say. He's saying something
goofy. Goofy guy, man. I got some built-up tension y'all need
to release. >> No. No, no, no. I'm not going anywhere near
that. >> Buddy, buddy, the guy rage-baited clips before
rage-bait was a thing. Yeah, he could be on on top of the Twitch
game in terms of Politics is a thing now. He can do the politics
and do the rage-bait and and the uh the viral clip [__]
It's literally what he does. Like, he would absolutely be on
top if he was still on Twitter. Are you kidding me? But the the
fact that Destiny is still live to this day is a miracle. Like,
brother, everybody who's tried that route are they're irrelevant
at this point. Like, that's insane.
Everybody who's tried that route is irrelevant at this point.
I mean, Asmongold's got Twitch, but Asmongold's way bigger on
YouTube than
Asmongold is way better at that game. Not better at directly
debating, I would
Yeah, I I don't know what actually he's saying
I will agree that Destiny could have had a big platform. Like,
maybe he would be a lot bigger with Twitch. Maybe. But then I
don't know. It's also not demonetized. That's true. That is true.
Well, whatever. It's I
The whole thing about like, I guess Destiny doesn't see
cloud reviews. This is This is like a totally insane thing to
say.
I I have no idea where this came from.
The next part where maybe Destiny would have been a lot bigger
if he was on Twitch. Possibly. Entirely possible. I think he
always was going to go to YouTube, though.
I I'm surprised Asmongold stayed on Twitch, to be honest with
you. Anyway,
weird. Weird, but funny. Okay, that came in and then we had what?
This one I was going to do as well, this other Arc clip. Arc's
going hard. He's going real hard with these Hasan hate clips.
Okay. Has- Hasan proclaims peak HasanAbi Derangement Syndrome.
comments keep you out of the news cycle, then I'm happy. No,
the problem is we have officially reached
we've officially reached like peak HasanAbi derangement syndrome,
which means
which means that everything that I say on this broadcast as a
joke will be used against me, against everyone, against your
grandmas.
Okay, against everybody. Like anything that I say on any podcast
appearance or on this broadcast will and can be used against
me. It's official. We are now we are now
full-blown in HasanAbi derangement syndrome in mainstream news.
Um, we went from we went from HasanAbi derangement syndrome in
like the commentary sphere and right as the commentary sphere
had started shifting
in the the way that they perceive me.
We we we moved on. Right as the commentary sphere was like, "Yeah,
maybe this guy
Cringe. Anyone that says HDS should be put down? No. No, HDS
is perfectly appropriate for what the actual political actors
are doing.
I don't really care like the commentary people make a lot of
money from this. This is people trying to make this argument
sincerely and they're [__] embarrassing. That is
HDS, absolutely.
Uh, the the commentary sphere or whoever streamers like talk
about Hasan doing the obsessed thing kind of cringe, to be honest
with you. But dude, the the HDS thing is totally true for all
of these political organizations who are attacking him. evil
psycho that we presented him as.
we we turned around and now the entirety of the mainstream is
doing it.
This is from The National Review, by the way. Hasan [__]
is the enemy.
Stop trying to be Trump. We're going to copy Trump. Cringe.
I mean, it's just a commonly used cultural phrase at this point.
Trump didn't You understand Trump didn't coin that phrase himself,
right?
You Wait, Side Sidis, do you think Trump made up the term Trump
Derangement
Wasn't it MAGA? It was MAGA, but Trump didn't make it up. You're
not copying Trump. It was like MAGA who used this as a way to
like try to say you guys are going crazy about this for no reason.
But that I don't know, it seemed kind of true, man. At least
for the people who said he was like losing his mind who had dementia
in 2016 He had dementia in 2016. Like that's Derangement Syndrome.
Come on.